the presidential debate is an unfiltered
forum
heavy on style and hopefully some
substance just like mike's place in
portage
county ohio an area that's been up for
grabs
in the past three elections
do you think this debate's gonna be as
colorful as your bomb
well it depends how much you drink i've
got a case ready
do you think you'll need to to get
through it no i am going to watch it
what are you wanting to hear
see if biden remembers his name i'm
kidding
and see and hope he's that incompetent
no
i think i think he's a wonderful man and
you know i think they both mean well
they just
have different ways of meaning well
hopefully they're nice to each other
how do you think joe biden will perform
on a debate stage
i'm not sure i'm really not sure
i hope he's ready but i'm not sure are
you worried
he's going to stumble yeah yeah
who do you think is going to win i'm
going to be honest with you i think
donald trump is going to like
wipe the floor with joe biden he's
certainly been ramming home the idea his
opponent would be asleep
at the wheel but that could backfire if
he doesn't fit the caricature
this will be their first face-to-face
showdown albeit with a limited audience
and no handshakes
they'll have six topics their records
covered 19 the economy the supreme court
race and violence and the integrity of
the election
all in just 90 minutes
biden may well inflict some extra pain
by playing on allegations about donald
trump
avoiding paying federal taxes for years
does that matter as long as he was
following the rules because there's a
lot of rules out there that the rest of
us don't
know but unfortunately sometimes people
who
have more money know the role those
other roles the rest of us don't
or they take bigger risks undecided
voters say
they'll be looking for signs of
sharpness and civility
but they appear to be a rare breed this
year
you think a lot of people are just
locked in their lanes they already know
who they want
i really do feel that people are just
locked with their decision
and i don't think the debates really are
going to sway people one way or the
other
and even in previous elections i really
didn't think that that was
the case i think people know who they're
going to vote for
style you can see the split here
who wins that slim middle ground maybe
more about
psychology than politics cordelia lynch
sky news
portage county ohio